joe musgrove on the hill tonight as the
padres try and get it going in front of
a sold out crowd against the
philadelphia phillies now the phil's
have been able to get base runners in
the first inning but for the most part
have had trouble scoring oh one pitch is
swung on engulfed in the air out to
right center field tatis looks and this
ball clears the wall it's a solo lead
off home run for o'double herrera
here's bryce harper two two pitches
swung on and lined in the air out to
right field a base hit for harper
saguero will throw on the brakes over at
second base
that's three consecutive base runners
for the fields
[Applause]
got him
finished him with a fastball 95 miles an
hour from joel musgrove and that is his
first strikeout of the night two down in
the top of the first
and miller out to center trent grisham
will track it
and make the play to end the inning so
joe musgrove gives up the lead homer to
herrera with the phil strand a pair well
aaron nola's on the hill he's throwing
to andrew knapp now aaron's obviously
gonna have to mix it up and he's got an
excellent curveball and
he's gonna have to use all his pitches
against this club they can swing the
bats three one pitch is popped up andrew
mccutchen is there and there's one away
well here is fernando tatis junior he
swings the first pitch and lines it
right to dd gregorius and there's two
away
and he gets machado to pop up on the
first pitch
brad miller is
there and he makes and he makes the
catch that's a seven pitch inning for
aaron nola start for the right-hander
fills with a one-nothing lead in the top
of the second inning the batter will be
the catcher andrew knapp and musgrove
makes very quick work of him second
strikeout of the night
and at the top of the zone strike three
called a one two three second for joe
musgrove and he caps it with a k well
and now the moment we have all been
waiting for one out here in the bottom
of the second austin nola will come to
the plate no balls and two strikes
and a swing and a miss he got him with a
96 mile an hour fastball
he absolutely cut that one loose that's
the hardest fastball he's throwing
tonight and maybe maybe the hardest one
he's thrown the entire time look at that
reaction
one two pitch got him with a breaking
ball two strikeouts in the inning for
aaron nola
six up and six down for the right-hander
two balls and two strikes disagree two
two swung on a miss strike three another
good breaking ball by musgrove four
strikeouts on the evening now for joe
too quickly away here in the third and
that'll bring up bryce harper
one pitch hit off the hands and floats
into left field and bryce harper's two
for two today
harper runs and nola's throw down to
second
he's in time good throw great tag by
fraser and for the moment at least bryce
harper is out and the top of the third
inning is over
one two pitch strike three called got
him on the outside corner three
consecutive strikeouts for aaron nola
well that's strikeout number four for
aaron nola and there's two away and this
is that another comeback sinker right
here he freezes the left-hander again
when his sinker's working like that look
out because now he's able to utilize it
to right-handers nice he looks like he's
got an awfully live arm right now great
too swinging a miss and aaron nola
strikes out the side and he has struck
out five straight padres
and he is through three and has a
one-nothing lead
nice battle there between a couple of uh
very talented guys but musgrove strikes
out mccutcheon for the second time
tonight and two outs here in the top of
the fourth yeah there's at first miller
at second two down and he grounds this
one just fair at first base hosmer will
take care of it and that will take care
of the phillies here in the top half of
inning number four a couple of two out
walks and a couple of guys stranded the
2-2
strike three call fastball at the knees
on the inside corner absolutely perfect
pitch there for marinola
who has now struck out six batters in a
row looks like he's going to change up
here
seven in a row for aaron nola
check out the movement right here this
is actually a change up that knapp
wanted away and it started out on the uh
in the middle of the play actually on
the outside part of the play they ended
up down and in that's how much movement
he had on this change up right here and
as i said he must be doing something
mechanically to keep his fingers on top
of the ball to make that ball rotate
down
got him perfectly plays fastball on the
outside corner seven strikeouts for
musgrove and a one two three fifth
inning we are midway padres will come up
looking to get some run support for
number 44.
one two
ground ball right side gene segura is
there
an easy toss on to first
aranola has sat down the first 15
batters of the ball game a 12 pitch
inning we head to the sixth
and up fields
the competitiveness and the ability to
keep his team in games is really
remarkable as is manny's ability to do
that
out number two in the top of the sixth
and that is the manny shift just
incredible and uh the awareness of the
speed of dd gregorius
getting down the line and what a pick on
the back end by eric hosmer
utilizing that big glove because he had
to get rid of it that one hop
maintaining that
left toe on the back part of the bag
two outs here in the sixth pinch hitter
jerickson pro far will pinch hits and
nola's got it working today
sharply hit caught by brad miller for
the final out here in the sixth
18 in a row for aaron nola to start the
ball game
a nine pitch
sixth for aranola
and now back to work on nola who has
thrown only 63 pitches
[Applause]
grounded to the right side kind of a
tweeter and off the glove of miller into
right field the padres have their first
base runner of the night okay so we'll
see aaron in the stretch for the first
time tonight
2-2 swinging a miss he got him eight
strikeouts for aaron nola and there's
one away here in the bottom of the
seventh
first pitch is into center field in a
base hit the first of the night
grisham's rounding third he will score
and we're tied at one
serenola back out to hit
2-2 line drive out to right field
towards the gap tatis over he's not
going to get there and it goes to the
wall nola's around first he's headed for
second and he will pull up there with a
lead off double here in the eighth
really nice at bat nice short swing
stays over the ball and drives it to
right field and tatis even with his
athleticism can't quite get there and
the bases are loaded
and it's inside and he hit him and a run
comes home and the phillies take a two
to one lead
well i know dee dee didn't want to get
hit in that elbow again but the fields
will take that gift gift wrapped him 2-2
from adams
way inside and he got him another comes
run comes home and it's 3-1 phils
1-2
strike three called got him looking on
the inside corner double digit
strikeouts for aaron nola well aaron
nola's back out to work 3-1 lead and
he's going for a complete game
one two pitch
swinging a miss number 11 for aaron nola
and there's one away here in the nines
are down two runs and down to their
final out in the bottom of the ninth
inning cronin worth in the air to deep
right center field dankoski racing back
gonna go
what a huge home run for the padres in
this offense
trent grisham will be the batter the one
two
that one kicks away here comes frazier
that is the ball game and that is a
winner
a signature win in innings padres were
down to their final out in the bottom of
the ninth they tie it and they win it on
a wild pitch in the 10th